argument that you need to improve the
economies of Africa before you can solve
this problem first of all I mean it's
like just will it ever happen in
anyone's lifetime who knows are you
willing to sacrifice the future of
Europe to that personally not but
secondly it's a fallacy Theresa May used
to say this during the migration crisis
used to say we need to work at improving
the economies in the countries people
are coming from flat out wrong you can
improve the economies nice thing to do
good thing for those people that doesn't
solve the migration problem in fact a
lot of the evidence shows if if the
lifestyle of the people in a particular
country rises in Africa slightly you get
more migrants coming to Europe because
they have the means to come to Europe so
this is all built on a set of massive
fallacies